What's up, Marvel fans?
We're here with Tom Holland,
who plays Peter Parker.
This is one of the biggest
Spider-Man films ever made.
What was your reaction
when you read the premise?
Oh, man.
I was blown away.
I was also so skeptical.
I just-- at the
time, I was like,
there's no way that they
could pull this off.
There's no way that
they'll be able to bring
these villains back
into this universe
and make it make sense.
But they did.
And they've done it in
a wonderful fashion.
The movie is incredibly
heartfelt. It's funny.
It's emotional.
It's exciting.
And you know, Jon
Watts has really
knocked it out of the park.
So to be here tonight
celebrating this movie,
I honestly cannot even begin
to explain to you how happy
I am and how excited I am.
If you had told me 10 years
ago that you'll be playing
Spider-Man in a movie like
this, I would have been like,
you're a liar.
Well, in a movie
like this, exactly.
Look at all-- look
at all these people.
They love you!
Movie like this-- you're playing
opposite super villains from
previous Spider-Man movies.
What is that like?
It's incredible.
I mean, I've been a huge fan of
these movies since I was a kid.
I remember seeing Toby's movies.
I remember seeing
Andrew's movies.
So to get the chance to share
the screen with their villains
has been one of the most
rewarding aspects of my career.
And I'm so lucky
to be here tonight.
I can't wait to share
the night with them.
And I'm seeing Tom Rothman
over there, my boss who I
love who's been so kind to me.
I want to go and
give him a big hug.
And honestly, I
am beyond excited.
Peter goes through so much--
the death of Tony Stark,
Mysterio letting him
know his entire identity.
What is that like for
Peter Parker in this film?
It's tough.
I mean, everyone's been
asking me in the press,
can you relate to it
because you're famous?
But I'm famous
for making movies,
and he's famous for
being a mass murderer.
So it's slightly different.
But it's been a very
exciting challenge, something
I've really enjoyed
taking on, bringing
to life in the character.
It definitely tonally
shifts the movie.
It makes the movie feel very
different to the previous two,
which is great.
I love change, and
I love this movie.
And I love everyone here.
And it's awesome.
Tom, you got a busy night.
Enjoy the premiere.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]